تسأل كارولين هل هناك
درجة حرارة مثالية يتكاثر فيها الفيروس بشكل
أسرع ،
لذا أعتقد أن كارول تسأل
عنها داخل الجسم
عند درجة الحرارة التي يتضاعف فيها الفيروس بشكل
أسرع.
درجة الحرارة المحيطة والبيئة
التي يوفرها جسم الإنسان
لدرجة الحرارة العادية هي المكان الذي يحبه الفيروس
وغالبًا ما نبدأ الحمى في
زيادة درجة
حرارتنا لمحاولة جعل جسم الإنسان أقل
ملاءمة للفيروس ، لذا من المحتمل أن تؤدي زيادة
درجة الحرارة إلى
تقليل  سرعة هذا النسخ المتماثل
أن هذا ليس علمًا دقيقًا
ولكن هذا جزئيًا هو سبب استجابة
الجسم بالطريقة التي
يتصرف بها لويس يسألني لقد عادت للتو من فلوريدا
واختبارها إيجابيًا ،
ما الذي يمكنني فعله لأجعل نفسي أقل
قلقًا
جيدًا لويس أولاً وقبل كل شيء  أنا آسف ،
أنا آسف لأن نتيجة الاختبار إيجابية ،
أنا آسف
لأنك تشعر بالقلق ، أفهم ذلك ،
ومن الواضح أنني لا أعرف الكثير.  باستخدام
خلفيتك ، تاريخك ، كم عمرك
من ظروف موجودة مسبقًا ،
يجب أن تضع في اعتبارك أولاً وقبل
كل شيء إذا كنت
قد حصلت للتو على نتيجة إيجابية ولم تكن لديك
أي أعراض من
الواضح أنها ستكون موقفًا
مختلفًا عما إذا كنت قد بدأت
لأشعر بالمرض ،
أعتقد أن هناك بعض الأشياء التي
يجب عليك القيام بها وأود أن أوصي بهذا
بصراحة
لأي شخص يشاهد بغض النظر
عما إذا كنت قد أثبتت نتائج إيجابية أن
الرعاية الصحية عن بُعد أصبحت مشكلة كبيرة في هذا
البلد ،
أعني عدد الزيارات التي تحدث الآن
عبر الشاشة
حيث يمكنك التحدث إلى
مقدم الرعاية الصحية الخاص بك
مثل هذا أعتقد أنه زاد بشكل كبير
خلال العام الماضي
، أعتقد أنه من المهم أن
يحاول الجميع إعداد كيفية القيام
بزيارات الرعاية الصحية عن بعد مع طبيبهم
تحدث المستشفى الخاص بهم إلى مكتب طبيبك
أينما كنت تحصل على رعايتك وقم
بإعداد ذلك الآن ، قم
بتنزيل البرنامج على جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بك
كل ما يتطلبه
الأمر حتى تتمكن من  قم بزيارات الرعاية الصحية عن بعد
وأنا أتحدث
عن هذا الوباء ولكن حتى بعد
ذلك سيكون هذا
مختلفًا وأعتقد أن لويس سيساعد في تهدئة
بعض قلقك بالإضافة
إلى القدرة على الحصول على هذا المورد
لنفسك شخصيًا إذا كنت
تشعر  مريض على الإطلاق يعالج الأعراض
إذا كنت تشعر بأن مزيلات
الاحتقان تأخذ شيئًا ما لعلاج
الحمى
لديك ، فقد ترغب أيضًا في التفكير في قياس مقياس
التأكسج الكلي لنبضك وكمية الأوكسجين
في
دمك ، يُسمى مقياس التأكسج النبضي ، يمكنك
شراؤها الآن.
اجعلها أسهل في الحصول عليها الآن ، فقط قم بقياس
أكسجة الدم لديك
وتأكد من بقائها طبيعية ، أتمنى
لك الأفضل مرة أخرى ، آسف لأنك
تمر بهذا الأمر ، أنا آسف لأنك
قلق حيال ذلك ، وأتمنى أن أفهم ذلك
يساعد قليلاً
مع القليل من المعلومات التي
أعرفها عنك ،
أنا متأكد من أنك تلقيت الكثير من
الأسئلة حول الحمل
ولقاح ما نتعلمه الآن
جيدًا نحن نتعلم الكثير أكثر  قد
تتذكر أن النساء الحوامل لم يتم
تضمينهن كجزء من التجارب الأولية
وهو أمر غير معتاد في العادة
لم يتم تضمينهن ولكن
هناك نساء حملن
خلال تلك التجارب الأولية
وكان هناك الكثير من النساء اللائي
كن حوامل قلن.  أنت تعرف ما الذي
سأفعله وأحصل على اللقاح
على أي حال خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية والآن
هناك بيانات
عنها بالإضافة إلى بعض الدراسات الأصغر ،
والخلاصة هي
أن اللقاح يبدو آمنًا عند
النساء الحوامل.
أن اللقاح في الواقع
يوفر حماية أفضل للأجسام المضادة
من الأجسام المضادة التي يصاب بها الأشخاص من
الإصابة بالعدوى بشكل طبيعي
وأن بعض تلك الأجسام المضادة سوزان
ستنتقل فعليًا
عبر المشيمة ومن خلال
حليب الثدي إلى الطفل
حتى تعرف أن المولود الجديد يمكن أن يتمتع أيضًا
ببعض الحماية
مما  يحاولون معرفة
ما هو أفضل وقت لإعطاء جرعة
من اللقاح للمرأة الحامل في
الثلث الأول من الحمل.  أكثر من
الآخر هل هناك لقاح واحد قد يكون أفضل
من الآخر هو إعطاء جرعات لأشياء مختلفة من
هذا القبيل
ولكن بشكل عام تعلم أن النساء الحوامل قد
أخذن اللقاح بالفعل
وهناك الآن
أدلة متزايدة على أنه آمن وفعال
يفعلون  جزء للمساعدة في
وقف انتشار kovid 19 وهم
يشمرون عن سواعدهم للحصول على التطعيم الكامل ،
لا يزال هناك الكثير مما
يُنصح بعدم القيام به ،
لكن تجربة سريرية جديدة قد تغير من أن
هذا سيساعد
في اتخاذ قرارات مستنيرة تستند إلى العلم بشأن
الاستخدام الشامل والتباعد الاجتماعي
بعد التطعيم في الوقت الحالي لأولئك الذين
تم تطعيمهم بالكامل ، لا يزال مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
ينصح بعدم
السفر ويستمر في التوصية بالأقنعة
والتباعد الاجتماعي
ما لم يكن حول مجموعة صغيرة من
الأشخاص الآخرين الذين تم تطعيمهم بالكامل
أو مع أولئك الذين يعانون من مخاطر منخفضة
غير محصنين ومن أسرة واحدة
، التجربة الآن  جاري البحث في
كيفية
انتشار covid19 من خلال دراسة 12 ألف
طالب جامعي في أكثر من 20
جامعة
في جميع أنحاء العالم  نأمل أنه في غضون
الأشهر الخمسة القادمة
أو نحو ذلك سنكون قادرين على الإجابة على
السؤال المهم للغاية
حول ما إذا كان الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم
يصابون بالعدوى بدون أعراض ، وإذا فعلوا
ذلك ، فإنهم ينقلون العدوى إلى الآخرين
.  اللقاح على
الفور ، سيحصل النصف الآخر على
اللقاح بعد أربعة
أشهر ، سيقوم الطلاب بملء
الاستبيانات وسيقومون بمسح أنوفهم
يوميًا
بالإضافة إلى تقديم عينات دم ،
كما سيقدم جهات الاتصال المغلقة
عينات عند إصابة هؤلاء الأشخاص بالعدوى ،
وكم مرة إذا كانوا مصابين
بدون أعراض ،
مقدار الفيروس الذي يحمله في
أنوفهم ، وهل ينقلونه
إلى الأشخاص الذين هم على اتصال وثيق بهم ،
ستساعد هذه الإجابات في تشكيل
توصيات بشأن المستقبل للتطعيم
الكامل للصحة في اللحظة التي أوفرها لك